right which is organized by Bui where we
implemented a system for offensive
content detection and we came out second
and we just not talk about that so why
call it simple please because we were
given and we have to come up with a
solution a data we have to collect data
we have to make a system we have to
present everything so we have to think
simple and implement but the main topic
was deep learning
so with now deep learning we all think
like how can we complicated system with
so now I try to find out how we can
convert our thinking in a very similar
way only to focus towards the problem
not towards the technology so challenge
which was organized by wanted by where
we organized by launchpad so when we
thought about that yeah right now what's
the situation like so well since I'm
working on sarcasm on decent Fred sees
that I can do start booting so then we
team up we try to collect data first
we've had our data set which was given
to me from 20 college from our atom
research center which was like 119 K
then we find out trying to find out all
of the resources there was like a hate
speech data set there was offensive
content data set there was yeah there
are many templates that we collected
those and we decided okay we're gonna
stick to social media
so when we we have to find out if the
problem we find out this was actually a
thousand one out of ten parents actually
know about them so right now in social
media we are still in age all of the
next generation has social media but not
all of the previous generation has
social media so they don't know what's
happening there and if I ask my father
oh go to social media and open an
account I don't care about it
so it's possible so but still right now
how can make a system where you don't
need to create any future account or any
social media account but you can still
monitor so that was the main intention
and as with that stuff so here you can
see that actually social in social media
we find out there's another chart and
find out that mostly happens with a
teenager like age of 12 to 8 at 24th
after range and they mostly use Facebook
and Instagram that's a high amount and
that's where actually they get so much
bully but since we were in a forty hour
competition and I've always worked with
Twitter so it's equal to the Twitter
also still have a lot of cyber bullying
which you find out now in terms of cyber
bullying is it only children who get
sorrowful it or is the children who gets
who bullies other children look
pupal it's a handicap only by the
teenager or young people so there's a
phrase I know
charity begins at home and that's true
that's why we got the boutique-y round
from and is why first cyber bullying but
still she caught foodies so then you
find out okay there do one thing I
joined there too just for fun let's make
a Skywalker a bad guy to fight with the
bad guy so with the bully
[Music]
so then we started looking for emotional
database we find out an emotional eater
and then you follow yeah now I can
actually create from their previous
means I can actually create their mental
state so if there are getting bullied
multiple times I can face what's their
mental status if they're getting really
sad that should be allowed to the band
so that's why I come here and he says
there is no escape so he's always come
early for so that's the troopers so
there is 3k doesn't we find out what if
170 thousand tweets there's a five
thousand nine that's a hit feed and
that's a motion detector which was near
about 30 KB and so so far it's fine we
have set the problem now thumbs if
learning now deep learning right now
it's like a complex so we all try to dig
what's happening inside and we want to
find out what's happening inside but we
always go away on our own idea what's
the main idea we go away from there
so if we think about models
and in that case if an find out those
actually are hierarchical structure
there was strong local correlation or
the features can vary anywhere so like
for image classification if you want to
classify cat so anywhere the cat
pictures they're seen in works better
because it can find out it doesn't
matter where its location for Arnon is
actually a the conceal data so that's
why there is a fix and times this won't
really work but again we are in
hackathon we have to make a system it is
fast I cannot have too much time to
Train and RNA so but it tastes nothing
so far I try to find out where I can
have a classifier which can use the CNN
as a taste so then I try to find out I
find out you tomorrow and I find out
they actually take the words as a
dimension and then they started doing
one deconvolution over the data and now
in image every data point is continuous
from the one point to another point is
all continuously but for word is
discrete that's why we have walked away
or we can learn our own way so I find it
ok now we can do the convolution of two
words together which is more like an
Engram system so it started doing that
and then I find out
[Music]
when I have oh I
it has a dimension but I have has a more
meaning than from mine so that's why I
started to change the convolution and I
find out that first I did a three row
and column but then there is a problem
of over P how we can solve it there it
comes
so to that point makes sense but if I
consider in a text level how which
dimension I should pick up which is a
important dimension I don't know what's
happening inside so it's still kinda we
are lost in this deep learning situation
so so we find out the result 119,000 we
split by 8020 specification that also
got good resolved then does it mean that
we saw takes PI CNN is it
we want to talk that question again
later on I have that but now I come to
the interface so we just make a simple
interface where we just put the ID and
it will give you who were whatever
tweets you are getting and what are the
tweets you are saying so what are the
tweets you are saying say is your mental
own what at which you are getting is how
much hate you were getting so is this my
golly the person who marketing send it
to me so he just trained that on the run
from today so it's not really great
interface we are modifying it right now
but you can see that on that moment
whatever he was saying for each person
was joy but they are still here is their
16.6 person so you can find out what's a
mental mode at that point do not come
back at the bottom we can see hate and
offensive like this is my difference of
data we find out this hate is more
serious case and we're talking simply
not that much so that's why we make up
we combine them by just one and 1.5 wait
and hit and often swing comes together
for the phone but later on we want to
include that as a fine line like how
your hate is going versus what's the
mental hold is change that's what we
love later on so the features work right
now what we created is allowing the
pattern to monitor so just type the
account and it gets all of the results
and also we can get not only your
children's mental Utley but also who is
sending tweets to your children they are
mentally so if you find out somebody's
angry and your children is sitting sad
and there is a hate with coming on that
so that's what we are progressing
reading around now we are improving our
UI to find out that the to the user will
just go there type it and find out if
it's actually it should be monitored or
not it should be taken care of or not
afterwards then we also find out eh
now hate is also something which right
now there's a blue whale I don't know if
many of you have heard about it or not
so blue whale is something the social
media again where they asked to do
something and at the end the fifty-eight
states they asked to suicide
so they manipulate there are some hate
speech there are some offensive language
they ask people to do something so if
somebody saw you throwing away hate
language then you can also monitor so we
can you actually can monitor the mental
health of a child mental health of your
surroundings and what he's done without
letting him know because we don't need
his user ID password you just know what
he's throwing away in the public now
since the spider so I just created uh
this is my github where
yeah
so ideally you scare us because I try to
stay it's like a really easy to write
any code and I try to create a
structured code so where you can see
that I'm sure of the data how you can
store the data so it's like a first
identifier then the level and any pit
detects if we keep the input format in
depth in this tabular format and then
you can easily change your model and
could run so to create the model it just
here we have I have a build model
function where you just change that part
to create the model and the rest and you
give the workers a part or really don't
want to use what a big part you want to
train your own with all you can be done
by just do if you give the water weight
path it will learn the water lake part
with the water wave if you can freeze
the water weight so that's all text
ability I have written the code which
you can find out in this one the links
will be shared and it's also you can if
you click just go there and for the data
set
here is the Train taste and development
and unfixed model actually stores all
the models so in a train
small one so I would say just later on
check it's just a three column the first
column is just identify second column
with a level third column is the ticks
yeah
so now we are all it has to be harder so
now we're going to and then I find out I
created a complex model but when I wind
up when I won the second prize of the
hackathon I actually make a really small
model just sixteen in so that means does
seed I ask the question does seen income
solve all that X problem no I will not
because I tried the same model on my
friend I have 51 cake
sarcasm it as a development aid and my
system which I which you also can find
out in mind Gita the sarcasm intercept
is also posted the code is also
available I tried that I got 91 so how I
went there there comes the solution is
here so when you find a text that's my
rough estimation right now my [ __ ] so
when you find the text where you can
clearly see the textual feature is
present within the text not too much
depth then you can actually go for CNN
it's a faster training you can get a
good without but if the problem is
really hard like really pragmatic where
you need to know the sequence of the
internal takes to understand sarcastic
or not then you must go for our name
then the time the spent on RNA will pay
well I have the system I what I did how
I actually measured these first I have
the water weight I freeze the water bed
I just train with CNN
I see how much scene and can pick up I
dropped the scene and then I just added
only to illustrate I find out how much a
listing can pick up I dropped everything
and
and it's DNN deep neural network all
fully connected Network and training and
I find out how much it can get so by
doing this I find that when the it's
sequence is needed we're more pragmatic
and deep complex network is there you
need this RNA to understand you this
memory you need the memory element to
get a better result otherwise just with
this Union you can find a linguistic
pieces but not too much step even try it
with ten layers of staining but still no
better result we go now
which is actually we start to think now
now in these are later on or to the
phone line so there's a line that what
it means to be alive by a robot so there
are right now we have a small robot now
about in our lab which we cannot
demonstrate soon I think I'm gonna post
a link in my slides later on so we're
gonna talk about embodied storytelling
now there's one feature we find out why
we make this it's not only human who
should be monitored it's also should be
a robot who should be monitored we think
about robots to be our friend but this
time to actually think them as a friend
so that we also need to do this
offensive content all these smooth
detection honorable otherwise we can
never accept them as a friend or as a
partner
[Applause]
so does anybody have any questions we
have a bit of a mind anybody want to
take it yeah okay so did you have on the
textual data or you actually had tweets
there in your data set
then why didn't you use why did you
stick your cell phone to text because
let's say if there is a tweeting there
you're such an [ __ ]
and it has like thousand likes that
hurts more probably right
when and if it's yeah and there is
another thing that if it's somebody I
don't know I just say BEC know you're a
nice I mean I don't know but if it's if
it's my friend or moreover my mom says
that I would be really hurt right no but
if you got it you know for sure
I'll to throw a rugby ball it's like you
put your leg there so say you mentioned
that if a parent wants to know what kind
of tweets their child is receiving what
should the parent know like it's enough
with knowing the Twitter folder of the
child or what
watch will watch children so you base
the RIA the tweets the child is
receiving in terms of mentions whenever
that is that 100 men have tried other
simpler algorithms like support vector
machines just to see how the score
differs from your solutions
so this CNN and RNN is really difficult
to train with small data sets now I'm
just curious how you overcome this
problems like overfitting and so we
mentioned also this max pooling so I was
just curious if you you had to use any
other tricks to to kind of no percussion
that's funny again for his great talk
[Applause]